techniques for preventing copying others  desires yeah this goes back to we were  talking about mimesis  which is a copying of other people's  desires  this is where meditation and alone time  has been really helpful to me  also just getting out of your peer group  because you copy things from your peer  group so retreats vacations trips  dropping yourself into completely new  environments is really good  because if you shift up your peer group  very quickly you'll notice how  you know  some of your desires no longer apply  another way is just to kind of see how  bundled your beliefs and desires are uh  if they line up very neatly with what  everybody else around you like your  close friends seem to want and they're  probably copied that's true of both your  that's true of your beliefs that your  political beliefs your economic beliefs  trivia desires etc  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  you